people of the Internet's retro here and
I know you have seen some of the insane
creations already for Animal Crossing
new horizons in today's video I'm gonna
take you through my very own theme park
[Music]
now keep in mind guys this is a work in
progress so be sure and let me know any
ideas you have for me down in the
comments I promise it's okay
you're not gonna hurt my feelings go
ahead tell me what I can do better
most importantly tell me what other
items I need to add to the theme park so
then this leads us right up into the
theme parks we got the fences here and
so you can immediately go left and guys
my son went crazy with the flowers I
haven't had the heart in town like it's
way too many so we got kind of like a
little aquarium here and also got some
bugs that were showing off then we have
the little jungle gym right here kids to
hang out and play so that's those are
our first two attractions that you get
on the left here then if you go to your
right that's gonna take you right into
the teacup ride now this is this part
that's still kind of unfinished here we
got we got a sled over here trying to
figure out what we're gonna do with that
a wrestling ring we've got the full
wrestling ring over here this will lead
you up to the main little fountain area
so this is kind of like the center area
right here's the fountain
I'm calling this like our little concert
area up here now right here this is my
favorite part so far this this part
right here is pretty close to being done
this is like our eating area you've got
vending machines snack machine
soda machine right here on the left now
we've got a shaved ice machine here
there it goes coffee maker here cotton
candy right here popcorn
see it poppin right there got the
popcorn going and then a water fountain
right here then we've got a table here
also a little bench right here for
people to sit and wait and then of
course what all good food areas need is
they need a place where people go to the
bathroom and they need a place for
people to throw things away we got you
covered this is like a little kids
playground area right here we got
in box a little slides is for the small
kids here's a place for the parents to
sit right here they watch the kids got
the pool right here always make sure a
lifeguard is on duty you want to just
relax under this tree hanging out at the
pool one day got you a little lawn chair
here this crack sea of teeth that he
treats it like a bed actually hold on
I've got it I've got it
I could see it in my head
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there okay now can I still put the
statue here yes I like what we've done
here how we've got the little statue
here this is where red comes to town
whenever he's selling his artwork
alright let's go ahead and do something
that I know we want to do I know we need
to expand this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right so I'll stand right on this to
line it up place the fountain look at
that man look at our nice little
fountain put a little branding on here
let's go Brandon going on there we go
there we go a little bit of branding
smashed logos yes dude the smash logo
might not be that hard to do actually
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but yeah man overall I feel like we made
a lot of good progress tonight guys on
the theme park here a lot of good
progress or taro coming through with the
great idea of of like making the Smash
Bros logo putting it on our wrestling
ring
alternating it with the retro logo here
so this is gonna eventually be our
seating area guys for perfect I should
say spectators for them to spectate the
wrestling events up here guys and gals
if you got any ideas from this video go
ahead and smash that like button before
you go and I will talk to you again soon
[Music]